nicholas cage has made not one but two
of the worst action movies ever made
which films are they and what antonio
banderas film is the worst reviewed film
of all time keep watching to find out
the original hitman movie based on the
moderately popular video game series of
the same name was dropped into theaters
in 2007. criticism was levied at the
movie's lousy script performances
effects and action sequences tragically
it was just enough of a financial
success to get a reboot enter hitman
agent 47 this reboot had one job despite
not needing to exist at all improve upon
the lackluster original while building
on the few things in it that worked as
evidenced by its eight percent tomato
meter this did not happen at all the
movie follows genetically engineered
killing machine slash assassin agent 47
played by rupert friend as he fights an
evil corporation to unlock the secrets
of his past the film also commits just
about every action movie sin a bad
script lackluster performances action
sequences that steal from far better
movies without even being inspired by
them to do something interesting
atrocious product placement worst of all
the movie is boring game over
bruce willis has starred in some
all-time winners like die hard but he's
also made some serious losers the
biggest most enduring stain being the
prince we have to imagine that liam
neeson turned down the lead role in this
irredeemable schlock fest in which
willis is supported by jason patrick and
rayne patrick stars as a former assassin
who comes out of retirement to take down
an old rival and rescue his kidnapped
daughter from a deranged willis sound
boring and cliche it is
just do yourself a favor and skip this
one bruce will thank you for it
ah nicholas cage once a respected actor
he eventually slipped and fell all the
way down the hollywood mountain emerging
decades later at the bottom covered in
bruises as an internet meme associated
with unwatchable schlock oh no not the
beast not the beast
i love my
eyes he has recovered a bit since then
but it'll take more than one or two
well-received indie films like pig to
salvage a filmography decimated by low
effort turds like bangkok dangerous one
of his most profoundly unwatchable duds
2008's bangkok dangerous shouldn't be
confused with the vastly superior 1999
thai original of the same name bangkok
dangerous gets just about everything
wrong in its attempt to tell the tale of
a lethal assassin who befriends a target
and gets hunted by a former client in
thailand the screenplay and the
execution are in a tug of war to see
which one is the most inept feature of
the film everything is sloppy and
uninspired and boring that last one is
the greatest tragedy of all the movie
didn't even manage to fall into so bad
it's good called classic territory it's
just blah and there's nothing worse a
film can be all the ingredients were
there for taylor lautner to break out of
the twilight series as a hollywood
superstar and yet it didn't happen why
well his first attempt to legitimize
himself as a bankable action hero 2011's
abduction went hideously awry and did
far more damage to his career than good
the movie follows loudner as nathan
harper a troubled philadelphia high
school senior who learns while
researching for a school project that he
was abducted as a child like many other
movies on this list the premise isn't
the problem if done correctly it could
have been a perfectly recommendable
action thriller unfortunately it was
done very very incorrectly on rotten
tomatoes where the movie enjoys an
arctic 5 approval rating the critic's
consensus reads a soulless and
incompetent action thriller that not
even a veteran lead actor could save let
alone taylor loudner that pretty much
sums it up lautner simply didn't have
the credibility the acting chops or the
support of competent writers and
directors to salvage this miserably
misguided bomb of a film there's a bomb
in the oven
what
there are a lot of bad movies based on
video games but most of them look like
cinematic master strokes compared to
1997's mortal kombat annihilation this
movie follows lou kang and his warrior
friends as they fight to stop the evil
shao khan from conquering earth realm it
all sounds fine enough but when it comes
to movies it's not the thought that
counts but the execution and oh boy did
this movie fumble that part the writing
takes no chances on anything and still
manages to confound the cinematography
is flat and uninspired the acting is
unworthy of a student film and the
special effects aren't special on rotten
tomatoes where the movie enjoys an
embarrassing 4 percent approval rating
the critics consensus reads with its
shallow characters low budget special
effects and mindless fight scenes mortal
kombat annihilation offers minimal plot
development and manages to under achieve
the low bar set by its predecessor
sounds harsh but after watching this
outrageous movie that shouldn't have
ever been made we can honestly say that
the critics took it easy on this inept
film mother
you're alive
too bad you
will die
mila yovovich is an all-time low budget
action queen headlining a whole
franchise of questionable quality in
resident evil but while many of her
movies have their fans you won't find
too many people willing to put their
neck on the line defending ultraviolet
the movie follows jovovich as violet a
martial artist infected with a kind of
vampirism in a dystopian world where
such a diagnosis lands you a death
sentence with her sword and friends by
her side she leads a revolution against
the tyrannical government that wants her
and her kind dead sound inspiring it is
for aspiring filmmakers who probably
figure they can at least do better than
ultraviolet
samurai cop wasn't exactly cruising for
an oscar when it was released in 1991
its name alone should have given that
away but if you need further proof get a
load of this premise joe marshall a
police officer trained by samurai is
tasked by the lapd with taking down a
japanese drug ring known as the katana
try to imagine the dumbest possible
execution of this already silly premise
got it well we regret to inform you that
this movie is at least twice as stupid
as that as you might expect the acting
is abysmal the actual filmmaking craft
is lazy and inept the fight scenes which
are really the only things a movie like
this needs to nail are staggeringly
fascinatingly bad made worse by the fact
that only a handful of scenes feature
swords instead of guns and what we do
get as far as swordplay is
unintentionally hilarious some of the
pratfalls when actors get shot or
punched are fine but the flat blocking
and overall dumpy looking presentation
looks like it was made for a soap opera
in the 70s luckily samurai cop achieved
the best possible outcome for a movie
worthy of this list it's established
itself as a bona fide so bad it's good
cult classic that's rarely the original
intention of a filmmaker but movies this
lousy need to take what they can get
why did you come under
i'm an undercover cop
nothing is more 80s than ruining the
legacy of a surprise one-off hit movie
with half a dozen increasingly lousy and
unnecessary sequels and one of the worst
offenders is the robocop franchise the
original about a nigh indestructible
crime-fighting cyborg is a disarmingly
sharp satire of american culture run
amok that absolutely bleeds glorious 80s
schlock the sequel however was a
significant step down pulling in less
money and far less critical acclaim than
the first and it was only downhill from
there unwilling to accept that the first
movie said everything the franchise was
capable of saying even after the
original star and director wisely turned
down the opportunity to do a second
sequel new director fred drecker
proceeded to beat an already dead horse
with 1993's
robocop 3. in this movie our
increasingly silly hero tries to avenge
his former partner while fighting to
save detroit michigan from falling into
the clutches of an evil mega corporation
as evidenced by its placement on this
list the movie was a critical and
commercial flop on the tomato meter
where it enjoys an appalling six percent
fresh rating the consensus reads simply
this asinine sequel should be placed
under rest between the hokey ham-fisted
messaging the outrageous but witless
action sequences and the feeling that
the franchise had essentially run its
course we can't help but agree i'd buy
that for a dollar
speed in which keanu reeves tries to
save the lives of bus passengers after
discovering the vehicle was rigged to
blow if its speed dropped beneath 50
miles per hour was one of the most
inventively entertaining action flicks
of the 90s speed 2 cruise control was
not reeves was smart enough to steer
clear of this misguided 1997 sequel but
sandra bullock and willem dafoe got run
right over in the story defoe hijacks a
cruise ship and sabotages its control
systems ensuring it will crash into an
oil tanker if it isn't stopped jason
patrick plays a cop vacationing with his
girlfriend that's sandra bullock who do
their best to bring the evil geiger down
it's later revealed that defoe's
character was seeking revenge against
the cruise line for firing him when he
got copper poisoning we seriously hope
the screenwriter wasn't trying to blow
minds with that reveal but whatever in
the end the heroes save the day by
steering the ship into a town on the
island of saint martin instead which
seems even worse it's worth noting that
the crash landing scene is still one of
the most expensive and elaborate stunts
ever filmed all this earns speed 2 8
razzy nominations and a crushing 4 fresh
rating on rotten tomatoes
the kirk cameron fronted left behind
movies based on the novels of the same
name weren't much to write home about
but they almost look like award season
contenders at this point because the
2014 nicholas cage fronted reboot was
historically bad bad enough to rank
among the worst movies that nicolas cage
has ever made which is really saying
something the movie only used the source
material sparingly and focus more on
action than theology maybe that approach
could have worked in more competent
hands but it certainly didn't pan out
here in this movie nicholas cage plays
rayford steele an airline pilot who's in
the air when the biblical rapture occurs
taking the souls of christians to heaven
and leaving behind billions of grieving
dumbfounded survivors meanwhile
rayford's daughter chloe tries to
navigate a panic-stricken city in search
of her brother who was among the
countless missing it actually sounds
like a great premise for a movie but the
filmmaking decisions made throughout the
story which are never short of baffling
ruin whatever potential the movie might
have had the result is a hysterically
incompetent action drama disaster
thriller christian movie that doesn't
come close to succeeding in any of those
genres
there's one name that stands head and
shoulders below the rest when it comes
to devastatingly unwatchable action
movie garbage german filmmaker uva bowl
often helming and self-financing video
game adaptations with predictably
disastrous results bowl makes movies so
proudly devoid of wit ingenuity and
competence that schlocky sci-fi
originals look like the godfather in
comparison one of his movies 2005's
christian slater fronted alone in the
dark is often and deservedly listed as
one of the worst films ever made the
movie is an adaptation of a 2001 video
game from the franchise of the same name
the only thing the movie has going for
it is that between the mind-numbingly
stupid screenplay special effects that
would have looked dated in an early 90s
tv movie and tara reid's performance it
is absolutely hilarious to watch
and here we are at the absolute bottom
ballistic x versus sever this mess about
two rival special agents who eventually
joined forces to take down a common foe
starred the usually reliable antonio
banderas and lucy liu
in a surprising turn of events the game
that was inspired by the movie was a
whole lot better than the film thing is
ballistic is not just a bad movie it's
not even just the worst action film ever
made it is literally get this the worst
reviewed film in the history of rotten
tomatoes we're not kidding not a single
one of its 118 reviews was positive
resulting in an ultra rare zero percent
fresh rating the critics consensus puts
it thusly a startlingly inept film
ballistic x versus sever offers
overblown wall-to-wall action without a
hint of width coherence style
or originality it's true and it's worth
reading the delightfully snarky reviews
if only because they are way more
entertaining than the film ballistic
indulges in every imaginable cliche and
choreographs its reveals so clumsily it
makes you wonder if the movie meant to
keep anything a secret from you in the
first place congratulations ballistic x
versus sever you are officially the
worst action movie of all time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite things to hate watch are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you